[Music]
you all know exactly who I am the bald
chemistry teacher looked around at the
men surrounding him in the desert
Cadillacs leather jackets blacked out
Shades the gang members shifted
nervously from foot to foot as the man
bragged openly about what he's done to
build his criminal Empire Walter White's
attention turned back to the men in
front of him a slight sneer played
around his lips now say my name the man
took a moment to reply as the desert
wind blew behind him he seemed to be
weighing his options realizing quickly
that he had lost all control over the
situation your your Heisenberg your gut
bang Walter White fell to the ground
dead the characters all around yelped in
Surprise Drew their guns and started
wildly pointing them around the circle
trying to figure out who killed the
great Heisenberg but his killer just
stared in awe from his couch in the
front room as the Netflix show kept
playing on the TV had the toy gun in his
hand really done that Josh had admitted
to himself that he had a problem a long
time ago but at least being a yard sale
addict was cheaper than just a regular
old retail addict actually in truth he
was also an estate sale addict a garage
sale addict and a thrift store addict
anywhere you could buy people's old junk
for rock bottom prices he would sniff it
out the Saturday that his life change
forever was just like any other Saturday
really in the sweaty heat of the
Atlantic City suburbs he hadn't meant to
stop by any sales today but one just so
happened to catch his eye there was a
box marked nerd stuff and he took that
as a personal challenge was this some
old lady's version of nerd stuff or a
veteran dungeon Masters Treasure Trove
the reality was somewhere in between the
two there were a couple of seasons of
Buffy on VHS a copy of the original Deus
Ex and some Legend of Zelda plushies it
hadn't really been worth stopping his
car for except for a little plastic
splash of color that caught his eye Josh
reached way down to the bottom of the
box and rooted around for it there was
no way it couldn't possibly be the toy
he'd spent all his childhood asking for
and never getting but in fact it was a
1985 Nintendo Entertainment System
zapper with an orange grip and Barrel
NES gray Bodywork and the Beautiful font
printed along the side it was
unmistakable he threw a wad of cash at
the old lady behind the table and rushed
back into his car quickly as he could it
was time to cancel his Day plans he had
a childhood dream to fulfill but no
sooner that he had got home and flipped
on his TV the dream Came Crashing Down
around him his old NES the one he'd had
since he was a little kid had sadly
keeled over it refused to power on no
matter what he did so that made his
zapper pretty much useless the best he
could do with it now would be to point
it at the TV and make pew pew noises
with his mouth so Josh opened up Netflix
and put on an episode of Breaking Bad
little did he know as he raised the
zapper to the screen that he was
actually in possession of
scp-674 nobody would know looking at it
on the surface even the most hardcore
Gamers wouldn't have a clue because you
can fully disassemble clean and
reassemble the zapper and get no
indication that it's anything other than
what it appears to be however as soon as
the gun is pointed at a television
screen or a computer monitor of any kind
it starts to pose a very real threat or
at least a very real fictional threat if
you shoot at the screen whatever media
is playing on it at the time will react
and adapt to what has just happened that
means characters on the screens will
react in accordance with the rules of
their respective universes in a grounded
realistic drama The Gunshot will behave
like any other killing or wounding the
victim with perhaps enough time for them
to give a dime monologue but in an
episode of Rick and Morty the shock
could manifest in any number of bizarre
and creative ways news crews that
witnessed the user shooting a person in
their live report will continue to cover
the incident as if it is part of the
ongoing story if you shoot Walter White
he falls to the ground dead Josh stared
at the screen in utter amazement he
didn't expect the writers to kill off
their main character just like that
wasn't there supposed to be another 9
episodes what would they do to fill all
that time as the episode played out it
seemed to mostly just follow Jesse
trying desperately to escape with his
money before it was too late he kept
glancing towards the camera for some
reason with a slight look of fear in his
eyes very strange creative decision
there Josh backed out of the show to
scroll through his continue watching
there was something a little creepy
about how he'd pointed the zapper at the
TV pulled the trigger and perfectly at
that moment a character had been shot
time to pick out another show without
any guns and murder for a bit you know
something safe The Familiar melodica
tune filled the lounge as various shots
of Dunder Mifflin employees busied
themselves shredding credit cards and
answering phone calls it never ceased to
make his worries go away seeing the
words the office appear on the screen he
settled into the couch watching as the
characters all gathered in the
conference room for some first aid
training the CPR dummy lay on the floor
with Michael Scott earnestly explaining
to the woman that the victim appeared to
have lost their limbs he laughed along
as the scene descended into chaos as
none of the employees took the training
seriously at all even though he'd seen
this episode countless times it never
got old absent-mindedly he pointed the
gun at the TV and pulled the trigger
bang Pam collapsed on the ground all the
characters Dove out of the way trying to
find cover behind their chairs not
daring to peek out at the camera only
the first aid ladies stayed on the scene
trying her best to resuscitate Pam it
cut to a shot of of Dwight talking to
the camera sadly he said that it was
almost funny but there was a real
heaviness in the moment his eyes were
red like he'd been crying off camera
Josh flipped the TV off and stared at
himself in the dark reflection was he
dreaming he hadn't just done that Hattie
fortunately for Josh and for the rest of
humanity he had not killed Jenna
frischer or Brian Cranston he hadn't
even killed their characters in the
shows at least not for anyone other than
himself Research into scp-674 shows that
the appearance of characters being
killed off on screen only exists in the
mind of the shooter for everyone else
the office Remains the Same as it always
was unfortunately for Josh however Pam
is now dead in that universe and will
always be whenever he watches an episode
it leaves a real Shadow over the later
Seasons but the characters apparently
managed to do a good job pivoting into
its new darker tone other shows that
have been tested in research conditions
have yielded interesting results like in
Star Trek it is impossible to actually
kill Captain Kirk instead various red
shirts always just so happen to dive in
front of him or fall into frame at the
pivotal moment with a small Dead Zone on
the right hand side of the screen
characters who witness enough shootings
have the sense to stick to that side of
the frame whenever the shot is on them
sometimes going so far as to plead
directly with a viewer breaking the
fourth wall in their desperation to
survive when Josh came back from a long
walk outside he'd convinced himself that
what he had seen earlier was all just
some vivid dream a dream he didn't
remember waking up from but definitely
wasn't happening anymore he'd play some
video games that's what he would do he
had decided he would just play some
Super Smash Bros and unwind anyone who
has ever said that sentence to
themselves will know firsthand how
foolish that is not 10 minutes later
Josh had definitely forgotten all about
his dream from before he was too busy
raging and cursing at the screen he
couldn't stand playing against King
dididi that stupid Hammer move always
got him without thinking Josh snatched
the zapper from the couch next to him
and blasted to DD right in the face in
classic Smash Bros style the giant
penguin King was launched backwards
flying off the screen in a blast of
colorful smoke but he didn't respawn for
a second his character just stood on the
screen awkwardly before it kicked him
back out to the character select screen
this time though King Didi's picture was
missing Josh couldn't help himself he
set up a free-for-all match straight
away picking all the characters he hated
to fight against Sonic Mario Pikachu
Bowser link Ness even we fit trainer one
after the other bang bang he felt a
strange sense of satisfaction once he'd
done his work great now the character
list only had the fair balanced ones
left they just so happened to all be his
favorite characters too but why stop
there Josh jumped across to El ring and
marched his night up through the gate to
stormvale Castle before Margaret even
had gotten through his opening cutscene
Josh had shot the boss right in the face
this boss battle that he'd been stuck on
for hours was over before it even
started what could he do now he put on
an episode of stranger things and shot
the demogorgon then moth Gideon in the
Mandalorian and some goblins in Hogwarts
Legacy the clickers from The Last of Us
took a couple extra shots but went down
easy enough he went over to his PC and
killed the Ender Dragon in Minecraft
without blowing up any beds he won a
game of Rocket League 53-0 after he shot
both cars on the opposing team he played
through doors in Roblox without a single
jump scare he would just shoot any
monster that filled his screen what
could be better he reckoned it was time
for more movies walking back across the
lounge spinning the gun around his
finger like a western he wondered if now
would be a good chance to hunt down all
the legendary animals in Red Dead 2. it
would certainly make the job a lot
easier if he could kill them all in just
one shot he'd just need to be careful
not to shoot Arthur by accident but then
Josh sat on the remote the TV flicked
over to an old rerun of Bob Ross just
that he'd been squaring up to shoot he
pulled the trigger before he could react
the canvas was splattered red from
somewhere off camera he heard the
artist's wheezing voice try to comfort
him there are no mistakes just
happy but he died before he could say
another word the exposition gun first
came onto the SCP foundation's radar
when a strange police report was doing
the rounds on an email chain amongst
local authorities they were all finding
a great deal of value from a man called
Josh who had turned himself in at his
local station in Atlantic City for quote
killing like everyone naturally the
police took his report very seriously
for all of about 10 minutes as soon as
they realized he was talking about video
games TV and movie characters the whole
case turned into one big joke they sat
Josh down in front of a TV and played
him episodes of the shows he was talking
about pointing out characters still
alive in scenes after he'd supposedly
shot them to death but he seemed to just
grow more distressed as he realized he
was experiencing this phenomenon Alone
by the time Foundation agents tracked
Josh down and took him in for
questioning the gun had moved on he
marched it straight back to the old lady
who'd sold it to him whoever then sold
it on again Josh's full account of
events and description of the zapper
were taken before he was administered
Class C amnestics and allowed to
continue with his yard sale addiction
uninhibited
scp-674 was found sometime later in the
possession of a 33 year old Caucasian
male simply referred to as Mr S A
reclusive man in a neighboring City Mr s
first gained the SCP foundation's
attention through his extremist
political blog in which he claimed to
have assassinated prominent political
figures news anchors and talk show hosts
while the truth of those claims was
demonstrably false it was clear from the
way he described events that he really
did believe the delusion after being
questioned it was discovered that he had
never left his home instead he stayed on
his couch watching news reports and
firing at any prominent figures that
appeared believing that he was indeed
killing them in the real world despite
claiming that he was using scp-674 to
prevent a military police state using
the device to assassinate so many
high-profile figures had the opposite
effect on his video reality in his blog
posts he described an increasingly
unstable Global Order martial law and
catastrophic events consistent with the
hypothetical release of two deadly scps
his house was barricaded with security
cameras set up in every direction the
more he had been using the gun the more
of the characters and journalists saw on
TV had threatened him claiming that the
SCP Foundation were on their way to
apprehend him and that he would face
retribution for what he had been doing
Mr s's intended ambush of foundation
agents failed while they appeared to be
dying on these security feeds he had set
up the agents experienced no physical
harm in reality as they apprehended the
man and seized
scp-674 while the majority of
researchers have deemed that scp-674 is
harmless to all but the mental
well-being of the shooter there was a
notably Sinister result to miss Master
s's time and Foundation detention alone
in his cell Mr s soon started to engage
in heated arguments with the security
camera set up to monitor him there is no
record of any voices in the room other
than his own yet he seemed to be locked
in a fierce argument all of a sudden Mr
s dropped to the ground Dead with three
38 caliber handgun bullets lodged in his
chest the entirety of his holding cell
was searched for evidence of a shooter
but none was found the exposition gun
remains in a locked plastic case in
storage site 23 aside from regular
cleaning and maintenance it is used
under controlled circumstances to
creatively gather intelligence about
further SCP activity in the event of the
site being compromised Personnel are
allowed to destroy the exposition gun at
their own discretion should it fall into
the wrong hands now check out scp-348 a
gift from Dad and scp-978 desire camera
for more